surplice is much more than a buzzword
and in this episode of GCP central's
you'll understand how Google cloud
platform makes service work for you if
you look back
most of the early days of Google cloud
focused on what could be called a
service offering as we've implemented
and offered products with this
fundamental principle you give us your
code we do the rest there are no service
to manage and no cluster to set up
provision or upgrade in addition the
infrastructure Auto scales to meet the
load demand and you're only billed for
the resources consumed as a developer
building web apps mobile api's or
back-end services this is your ability
to focus on the business logic of your
apps GCP offers a number of different
products to help you accomplish exactly
what you need let's take a look
functions as a service or faz is a very
popular approach to service compute
developers write a piece of code a
function that is triggered on an event
or on an incoming HTTP request this
function code can talk to a database and
to other services before it generates
itself another event or simply sends a
response back Google Cloud functions
supports multiple programming languages
such as Python nodejs Go Java and
Morecambe and these can be used with a
large set of libraries and frameworks
simply deploy your function along with
its list of dependencies which will be
resolved directly in the cloud and
configured the event that will trigger
its execution
this can be an HTTP event of course but
also file upload to a class search
bucket data changing in a database a
message being posted to a pop sub-q or
topic or several other events functions
can be assigned deployed time
environment variables they can be
deployed to any and multiple regions
from a single project and they support
up to several gigabytes of memory
functions can also be configured with
specific security constraints such as
least privileged access width per
function identity you can even use the
compute made a data server
to fetch identity tokens at runtime
Cobb functions are built by the number
of invitations the compute time and the
outgoing network or egress with free
first two million in vacations every
month Club functions are probably the
easiest way to access one of the many
powerful GCP services from machine
learning api's to other storage and
processing solutions that have been used
by customers implement everything from
glue code to fully flash micro services
based applications now as a developer
you may want even more freedom in the
languages and frameworks that you use
and most importantly you may rather want
to hand over a carefully crafted docker
container image instead of source code
cloud run is here to offer you a true
service experience if a stateless HTTP
container image is what you'd like to
use simply build the image upload it to
cloud registry and create a cloud run
service using that container your app is
now deployed and running in the cloud
and you can forget about provisioning or
managing servers cloud run does that for
you it automatically and quickly scales
up and down based on your incoming
traffic and even scales down to zero you
pay only for the resources that your app
uses down to the nearest 100th
millisecond because cloud run is built
with K native you can use it with your
own kubernetes engine cluster too with
cloud run on gke you can build and
deploy apps to your own kubernetes
cluster with the same easy experience
and benefits with a running on gke or
not cloud run supports deploying
multiple services in a single GCP
project either in multiple regions or in
specific namespaces when running in a
gke cluster each service exposes a
unique endpoint each service deployment
creates a revision and requests are
automatically routed as soon as possible
to the latest healthy service revision
finally each revision receiving requests
is automatically scaled to the number of
container instances needed to handle all
these requests note that a given
container instance can receive multiple
requests at the same time with the
concurrency setting you can
the maximum number of requests that can
be sent in parallel to a given Container
instance cloud run essentially gives you
the flexibility of modern container
based development with all the benefits
of a fully service environment auto
scaling to your applications needs if
you're building an entire web
application with multiple services and
would still like to deploy source code
while preserving all the service
benefits you should check out Google App
Engine App Engine has recently
celebrated its 10th anniversary and is
where you'll find Google cloud platforms
service routes App Engine is a managed
platform that lets you pick a language
you're most comfortable with
simply run g-cloud app deploy an app
engine will take care of uploading your
code and running it on Google's
infrastructure the second-generation App
Engine runtimes available for Java node
PHP Go and Python offer a truly
idiomatic experience with the ability to
use any language API and any framework
with readwrite filesystem access and
with isolation provided by G visor a
powerful open source sandbox technology
App Engine applications can be built
using multiple services each of which
can use different languages and can be
scaled independently each service can
offer multiple versions all active at
the same time and it is trivial for you
to set up staged rollouts or a be
testing across these versions with
traffic splitting App Engine takes
out-of-the-box tooling one step further
with full app performance management
tools available such as live debugging
of production apps
tracing of requests flowing across your
system and even CPU and heap profiling
of your app Google App Engine is a
mature service platform and not your
father's platform as a service modern
and more advanced applications can be
written with a combination of cloud
functions App Engine and cloud run and
both cloud pub/sub and cloud tasks are
popular and elegant solutions for
integrating these different parts
or even simply to combine multiple
functions cloud pub/sub is a simple
reliable and scalable event system
offering many too many asynchronous
messaging that nicely decoupled senders
and receivers it supports at least once
delivery and is global by default with
no infrastructure to manage just publish
and consume up to hundreds of millions
of messages per second cloud tasks on
the other hand offers a dispatch system
to manage the execution of large numbers
of distributed tasks it is ideal for
one-to-one asynchronous messaging and
comes with rate limit controls finally
cloud scheduler is a fully managed cron
job service enabling you to schedule
tasks that are invoked through HTTP
endpoints cloud pops up topics or App
Engine applications it's remarkably
simple and yet incredibly powerful to
use check it out all of these solutions
briefly discussed here are fully managed
and monitored logging and error
reporting are just built in with GCP
service you give us your code and which
ever artifact you prefer a function and
application or a container image and
we'll run it for you consider taking
free code labs linked in the description
below to explore these products and look
forward to upcoming episodes and more
overviews if you like this video please
like subscribe comment and share see you
soon for another GCP essentials video
you